[Música]
algunos sueñan con el premio toda la
vida el logro obtenerlo con tan sólo 39
años enmanuel macrón es de lejos el
presidente más joven de la quinta
república un hombre apresurado amante
del piano y de la filosofía economista
egresado de la escuela nacional de
administración ena el nativo de la
ciudad de amia se hizo notar en su paso
por el banco rothschild luego descubrió
el eligió como secretario general
adjunto con tan sólo 34 años ya se
ubicaba en la élite de quienes le
hablaban al oído al presidente dos años
más tarde este ambicioso treintañeros se
convirtió en ministro de economía un
ascenso fulgurante que generó
curiosidades a donde quiera que iba lo
esperaban los micrófonos enmanuel macrón
presentó sus ambiciones eliminar los
rojos que hay de manera concreta nuestra
economía e m son sus iniciales así como
las de su movimiento político en marcha
creado en 2016
tomo distancia con el socialista
françois hollande yo soy de izquierda es
mi historia pero hoy la izquierda no me
satisface uno de los pilares de la
izquierda son las 35 horas de trabajo
por semana una trampa para emanuel
macrón quien prefiere ver a los
franceses trabajando la mejor manera de
pagarse un traje es trabajando macrón
sacudió el paisaje político francés las
presidenciales de 2017 pasaron a la
historia por primera vez en la quinta
república ni la derecha ni la izquierda
llegaron a la segunda vuelta pro europeo
emanuel macrón derrotó a marín lópez
[Aplausos]
con menos de 40 años inició un
tumultuoso mandato por cinco años
chalecos amarillos en la fenomenal a la
movilización contra la reforma al
sistema pensional y por supuesto la
pandemia de kobe 19 las dificultades se
multiplicaron así como las críticas y el
presidente contraatacó
nos hemos convertido en una nación de 66
millones de fiscales y así no es como
solucionamos los problemas en los
últimos dos años estuvieron marcados por
la crisis sanitaria para salir adelante
macrón apostó por una vacunación masiva
aunque eso signifique según sus propias
palabras fastidiar a los antigua cuna no
solamente ponen en peligro las vidas de
otros sino que también restringen las
libertades de otros y eso yo no puedo
aceptarlo ahora candidato a la
reelección
emanuel macrón quiere lograr lo que sus
predecesores hollande y sarkozy no
pudieron quedarse cinco años más en el
el icio